[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مساء الخير لكم جميعا كنت دائما بتساءل من
انا صغير كيف ممكن شخص او فرد يقدر يغير
العالم
بعد ما قطعت هيك شوط كبير في رحلتي وفي
انتصف العمر
صرت عندي قصه ممكن اشاركها معكم
ممكن تجاوب على هذا السؤال هو قصتي نوعا
ما غريبه او غير مالوفه لكنني دائما اعتقد
انها تستحق
المشاركه
واليوم راح اعرف عن حاله بطريقه مختلفه مش
زي دايما رح اعرف عن حالي اليوم ثلاث مرات
اول شيء راح اعرف عن حالي بجوز طريقه شوي
مختلفه انا كثير
تم تعريفي محمد شاكر ودخل بالطقس في
المناخ بس بدي اورجيكم صوره لشخص هذا
الشخص اذا بتعرفوا مين هو هذا ممثل اسمه
هذا الممثل المثل في فيلم اسمه ذا ويذرمان
في قصه هذا الفيلم بتقول انه هذا الشخص ما
كان حدا يصدقه ولكن ظل مصر الى ان اصبح
مسماه ذا ويذر مان في الدوله اللي هو فيها
انا بحس فيه شويه شبه تقريبا بيني وبينه
الصوره التاليه
ما رح تيجي الصوره التاليه طيب
في شويه شمعه هذا صورتي وانا صغير
كنت عم بقرا خرائط جويه ليش ليش انا بعتقد
انه في في شبه في تشابه بيني وبين هذه
القصه انا اعرف عن حالي انا اسمي محمد
الشاكر شخص ولد معي حب وشغف في علوم
الارصاد والطقس والمناخ وهو مندمج معاي
وبدا معي منذ الصغر هذا تعريف الشخصي عن
حالي
طيب انا وعمر ست سبع سنوات شو كنت اعمل
كنت فعليا وحرفيا مجنن اهلي لانه كنت
دائما متنقل ما بين النوافذ والشبابيك
والنشرات الجويه واسال اسئله صعبه جدا على
الاهلي جابوها لان هي اسئله علميه دقيقه
واسئله ممكن تكون فضوليه جدا الى ان وصلوا
الى حد الاستسلام وقررت حينها والدتي
ارسالي الى مركز الارصاد الجوي الحكومي
ولعل اني اجد الكثير من الاجابات لكثير من
الاسئله اللي كنت اسالهم اياها في هذا
الوقت وبنت اروح على مركز الارصاد الجوي
الحكومي اللي هي اداره الارصاد الجويه حتى
اتعلم منهم كيف بتم عمليه التنبؤ الجوي
والرصد الجوي واسال كل الاسئله درجه وصل
الامر معي اني كنت حتى اداوم
شفتات معهم وانا ما زلت على مقاعد الدراسه
بعد ذلك حصل بعض الاحداث الفارقه في حياتي
هذه الصوره في عام 2006
تعرضت منطقه جنوب الاردن الى سيول جارفه
وللاسف توفي عده اشخاص بسبب هذه السيول في
هذاك الوقت
تتشكل هذا الامر صدمه لالي بانه المعلومات
الجويه والهوايه والبيانات اللي انا قاعد
عم بتناقنها هي فعليا قادره على حمايه
الناس يعني حمايه ارواح الناس
فكان هذا اول حادث شكل صدمه لالي بانه ايش
المشكله طيب فاعتقدت هنا ان المشكله هي في
طريقه ايصال المعلومه الجويه بطريقه توصيل
المعلومه الجويه فقررت حينها كان عمري 15
سنه تاسيس اول موقع الكتروني عربي يعلى
بالطقس في المناخ لتسهيل وصوره المعلومه
الجويه واللي لاحقا اصبح من اكثر المواقع
زياره واليوم موقع طقس العرب هو موقع
يستقبل ملايين بالعشرات الملايين من
الزوار وهذه كانت النسخه الاولى للموقع
لمكان عمري 15 سنه يعني انا كنت في مقاعد
الدراسه المدرسيه
شكرا
بعد صار عندي
هدف فارق اخر
وهو مضحك شوي
بكره في مطر
يجي شمس نيجي نحكي بكره ثلج يجي شمس نحكي
بكره طب شمس يجي مطر طيب ايش هذا الموقف
المحرج اللي تعرضنا له
على انا وفريق العمل كنا عارفين ان
المشكله تكمن في البيانات الجويه والخرائط
الجويه هي مش مشكله فينا ولكن كنا دائما
متبنين داخليا مقوله اسمها
ما عندك فرصه ثانيه للانطباع الاولي
الانطباع الاول صح فما عندك فرصه ثانيه
لهذا الانطباع فاللي ممكن يجي ويستخدم
موقعك ونشوف البيانات خطا شو راح يصير معه
ما راح يرجع
فقلنا طب كيف ممكن نحل هذه المشكله فقررنا
حينها انه نبدا بالتفكير في كيف ممكن نحل
مشكله البيانات وجوده البيانات الجويه هلا
بدي اعرفكم عن حالي مره ثانيه انا محمد
الشاكر
عندي شغف واهتمام وحب كبير في علم الارصاد
لكن انا امام مشكلتين لازم احلهم في هذا
القطاع المشكله ولا طريقه ايصال المعلومه
الجويه
ومشكله الثانيه جوده هذه البيانات الجويه
عملي طبعا في القطاع المناخي باتي يزداد
صعوبه يوم بعد يوم نظرا لهذه التغيرات
المناخيه اللي قاعدين من عصرها حاليا بس
انا بدي اسالكم سؤال
رغم انه السلايد عم بمشي معي اسرع لكن
سؤال لكم لما بحكي كلمه التغير المناخي
ايش بخطر في بالكم
السؤال بشكل ابسط لو غمضتوا عيونكم فعليا
فحكيت لكم كلمه تغير مناخي ايش ايش بخطر
في بالكم
عاصفه كارثه
اقتباس حراري
تغير الحراره
تغير في شكل الارض
شايفين احنا هون شو في قدامنا
انصهارنا الجديد في القطب الشمالي والصوره
اللي وراها كمان حنشوف مظاهر اخرى للتغير
المناخي لكن سمعت واحد حكم بس
اغلبنا ما خطر في باله كلمه واحده هي
المدن
المدن المدينه نعم المدينه هي اكثر
المناطق اللي بتحتوي على سلوكيات تعدي على
الطبيعه
فالمدن هي اللي بتنبنى فوق مجال العوده
الطبيعيه المدن هي اللي بتتوسع على حساب
الاغطيه نباتيه المدن اللي فيها
الانبعاثات المدن اللي فيها التلوث مدن
تحتوي على العديد والعديد من سلوكيات
التعدي على الطبيعه
والمدن هي ذاتها
اللي تتعرض لتبعات التغير المناخي فالمدن
هي ذاتها اللي عم تتعرض لسيول فيضانات
موجات حر موجات برد برد بحجم كبير
احوال جويه غير مسبوقه والناس ما بتعرف
تتعامل ومش قادر توصل لطريقه تتعامل مع
هذه الاحوال الجويه اللي بتعتبر جديده
اللي عم تضرب هذه المودرن
طب شو الحل
الحل مصطلح جديد هو اسمه التاقلم المناخي
هو قدره الافراد المؤسسات المدن الهيئات
الشركات الحكومات على التعامل مع حالات
الطقس القاسيه
بكفاءه
عبر انظمه انذار مبكر بتمكنهم من التخطيط
قبل بوقت بحيث يحمل الارواح والممتلكات
انا حتى شبهكم الموضوع اكثر لو زلزال صار
في اليابان بشده معينه هل شده التدميريه
تتشابه مع زلزال بحدث في منطقه ثانيه بنفس
الدرجه
ليش لانه اليابان دوله متاقلمه زلزاليا
واحنا ما نسعى فيه هون بتقص العربي لانه
نجعل من العالم متاقلم مناخيا ليصبح
العالم مكانا امنا للعيش
طيب
ايش المشكله اللي عم يحاول نحلها عم نحاول
نجعل من العالم مكان امن عن طريق التاقلم
المناخي
المناخ يحتاج الى شيء اسمه انظمه انذار
مبكر هذه انظمه الانذار المبكر تحتاج الى
شيء اسمه التنبؤ الجوي الدقيق تنبا الجو
الدقيق يعني من دونه ما في اشي اسمه انظمه
انذار مبكر ايش الانظمه انذار مبكر اصلا
هي عباره عن انظمه بتساعدنا انه نعرف بشكل
مبكر شو راح يجينا وبالتالي نقدر نتخذ
خطوات واجراءات لحتى نحمي انفسنا
وممتلكاتنا قبل بوقت بس لو كان التنبؤ
الجوي غير دقيق تفشل انظمه الانذار المبكر
طيب كيف بدنا نحل مشكله التتبع الجو
الدقيق الحقيقه ان العالم يعاني من عدم
وجود تنبؤات جويه دقيقه طب كيف اصلا بصير
التنبؤ الجوي هذا بعرف
التنبؤ الجوي في العالم يحدث بدي ابسط لكم
اياه باخذ صوره اوليه للكره الارضيه يعني
زي اللي باخد سكرين شوت للكره الارضيه هذا
الامر عم بصير بوفقى بروتوكول
يومي وفي اوقات يوميه على مستوى العالم عن
طريق مجسات ومستشعرات بتقيس الغلاف الجوي
في اوقات معينه فبتاخد هاي الاولى ناخذ
هاي السكرين شوت ونحطها بحواسيب بنسميها
فائقه القدره ايش عم تعمل هاي الحواسيب
عبر معادلات فيزيائيه تعمل عمليه محاكاه
تنتج صور مستقبليه اللي هي اسمها التنبؤات
الجويه طيب لو الصوره الاوليه غلط شو بدها
تكون الصور المستقبليه برضو غلط لو في
ثغرات الصوره الاوليه برضه راح يكون في
ثغرات في الصور للمستقبليه في هاي الصوره
انتم شايفينها امامكم هاي النقاط الحمراء
هي اللي بتبين لا الصوره قبل هي النقاط
الحمراء اللي بتبين
اماكن الرصد الجوي
والصوره شفتوها السواد الاعظم من الكره
الارضيه ما في اصلا صوره ما في رصد جوي
بساهم في الصوره الاوليه فقعدنا نفكر انه
احنا عنا مشكله بنحلها في هذا القطاع اللي
هو تحسين التنبؤ الجوي فافتكرنا طريقه
جديده في طقس العرب هي طريقه كانت نوعيه
ومختلفه والاعتماد على الذكاء الاصطناعي
في اثراء الصوره الاوليه للكره الارضيه
وهذا الامر اللي بيصير شكل يومي اعتمدنا
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي كثير من
الناس بتشارك صور كل يوم
للطقس او الحاله الجويه او المناظر
الخارجيه ذكرنا اليه الذكاء الاصطناعي
نقوم بتحويل الصور والنصوص وحتى الفيديوز
الى بيانات جويه نثري بها الصوره الاوليه
هذه بعض النماذج يمكن تشوفوها صور مثلا
شخص بصور امطار بنقدر نعرف عبر الذكاء عن
هذه الامطار عم تهطر في منطقه معينه او
الغبار او الثلج وغيره واصبحنا امام سيل
من البيانات الى ان ابتكرنا منصه داخل
تطبيق طقس العرب اسمها انت الراصد من خلال
هالناس بتاخذ صور واحنا من خلال هذه الصور
من حولها عبر الذكاء الاصطناعي الى
بيانات بتشتري الصوره الاوليه وبتفيد كل
الكره الارضيه
هذه واحده طبعا من العديد من المبادرات
اللي ممكن
احنا نعملها وانتم تعملوه بعد ما حصلنا
الصوره الاوليه وعم نحسن مازلنا في الصوره
القويه الكره الارضيه ابتكرنا انظمه انذار
مبكر لكل قطاع
ايش انظمه انذار مبكره ابتكرنا انظمه
انذار مبكر للدول حتى تحافظ على السلامه
ذكرنا انظمه انذار مبكر للزراعه حتى نحافظ
على الامن الزراعي ذكرنا انظمه انذار مبكر
للنقل حتى نحافظ على سلامه النقل وايضا
ابتكرنا انظمه انذار مبكر للصناعه حتى
نحافظ على سلاسل التوريد انها تضلها شغاله
بشكل كفو
يعني التغير المناخي بطلوا فقط مجرد مساله
جانبيه هو مساله بتخص امننا وغذائنا
وسلامتنا وحياتنا فهو تهديد وجودي يجب ان
اتعامل معه بهذا الشكل
طيب
بعد هذا الامر برجع بحكي مره تانيه كيف
ممكن الشخص او الفرد يغير العالم هذه واحد
من مبادرات عديده ممكن احنا نعملها نغير
العالم وانتم ممكن تعملوا كثير مبادرات بس
بدي اعطيكم مثال صغير لمبادره صغيره ممكن
انت من خلالها تغير العالم
احنا اليوم كلنا بنعرف انه تقريبا مستحم
ما بين 3 لخمس مرات في الاسبوع في منها
سبعه وفي منه ثلاثه
والاستحمام بكل دقيقه بخلينا نستهلك
تقريبا عشر بالترات من المي لو كل واحد
وفر دقيقه واحده يعني بوفر عشر لترات من
المي يعني قديش في الاسبوع اذا خمس مرات
خمسين لتر
يعني قديش الشهر يعني 200 لتر
من المي ممكن توفرها بس بدقيقه انك توقف
او تختصر من الاستحمام تبعك هاي المتين
لتر على مدار تسع شهور بتعبي خزان مي كامل
سعته عشرين متر مكعب طيب واختصرنا وعملت
الخزان المي شو بستفيد بعدين بتعرفوا انه
بهذه الكميه اللي انت عملت لها اختصار انت
قادر على تزرع شجره وتسقيها لمده سنتين
طب هاي الشجره بايش بتفيدنا هذا الشجر
بيفيدنا بكثير شغلات كمان شوي ممكن تظهركم
صوره بتبين لكم شجر شجر اول شيء مكان
يعطينا اكسجين ولا يسحب ثاني اكسيد
الكربون الشجر بيعمل على يكون موقل لكثير
من الحيوانات
والاحياء الفطريه الشجر ببرد درجات حاره
المدن الشجر ممكن يكون منظر جمالي قديش
مدننا افتقدت للاشجار قديش احنا اماكننا
اليوم نعيش فيها راح منها الشجر بعض
المبادرات الصغيره اللي ممكن انتم تعملوها
قادره انها تغير العالم نزرع شجره في
مدينه قادره تغير مدينه باكملها
هذه فقط بعض الافكار وحبيت اني اشارككم
معها لكيف ممكن احنا نغير العالم ما بدنا
ننسى انه ديننا الحنيه
حسم على الحفاظ على البيئه الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم يقول اذا قامت الساعه وفي
يدي احدكم فسيله فان لم يستطع الا ان تقم
الا ان يغرسها بل يستطيع الا ان يغرسها
فليغرسها او كما قال بمعنى اخر من لو قامت
القيامه بمصالحنا المحلي او عن جد اذا
قامت الساعه وفي احدكم شتله فصيل يعني
شتله واستطاع انه يغير قبل قدر المستطاع
فليغرسها الى ذلك الحد
يقول دينا الحنيف انه علينا واجب ان نحافظ
على البيئه والمناخ
المقدمه الاخيره الثالثه انا محمد الشاكر
نفس الشخص اللي وانا صغير وما زلت بحب
وبعشق علم الارصاد والتنبؤات الجويه
والمناخ
ومازلت بس على حل مشاكل هذا القطاع ولكن
اليوم بدير اكبر مركز للطقس ومناخ في
المنطقه العربيه بالتعامل مع زملائي
ودائما مستلزمين بمقوله اسمها لايش ابرح
وحتى ابلغ يعني ظلنا مصرين على انه احنا
راح نجعل من هذا العالم مكان امن للعيش
بجهود عربيه واسلاميه شكرا لالكم
[موسيقى]